happy blessed Ramadan to all my Muslim  followers  it's that holy time of the year again  where you'll be fasting for long hours  this is also the perfect time to make  significant changes to your lifestyle to  guide you through I've put together a  28-day weight loss meal plan and also  workout plan everything will be  available on my website and I've put the  links in the description box below and  let's commit to have a fitter fasting  month during the fasting month your  metabolism will slow down so it is very  important that you eat right to have  enough energy but don't overdo it do  read my tips and tricks' are making  healthier choices for iftar and suhoor  the portion sizes and also foods to  avoid and also do check out my tips on  exercising how often should you work out  how long how intense what types of  exercises and when it's the best time to  work out tag and share this on to a  friend who's fasting have a blessed  Ramadan